bonjour je m'appelle alex de louvigny
j'habite à sainte clotilde j'ai 25 ans
et je recherche un peu dans le secteur
du marketing je recherche un poste plus
dans le nord donc sainte clotilde de
saint-denis sainte-marie moi j'ai passé
un bac sur teknologik gestion spécialité
marketing je suis parti en métropole
après l'acquisition de mon bac un petit
peu pour me trouver voir un petit peu ce
que je désirais faire dans la vie j'ai
touché un peu à tout j'ai tenté de
monter mon entreprise un moment dans le
traitement de la corrosion en atlantique
ça beaucoup de vins de corrosion à la
réunion si d'ailleurs sinon j'ai une
expérience aussi en centre d'appels j'ai
travaillé un an pour pour une entreprise
trendeo e-marketing direct au sound a
touché les enquêtes de satisfaction je
répondais pour des clients sous
traitance était intéressant j'ai
travaillé dans le prêt-à-porter donc au
jour d'aujourd'hui je recherche un bts
en alternance
le dit gilbert commerciale toujours et
je cherche une entreprise justement pour
pouvoir le passer je parle créole jeu
je comprends très bien cruel
parfaitement je le parle en fonction de
mon interlocuteur c'est sûr qu'en centre
la paire on a toutes sortes des gens
c'est la population façon réunionnaise
donc il faut répondre à la demande et
surtout qu'ils nous comprennent donc
dernier à tous je pense de pouvoir
s'exprimer en français comme en créole
anglais espagnol bon j'ai un niveau
moyen après c'est une question de
pratique ge-servette de l'informatique
je sais les recherches sur internet pour
savoir ce qui m'intéresse qui apprendre
facilité voilà internet informatique
c'est un symbole outils pour savoir s'en
servir je suis assez observateurs je
suis attentif à l'écouté j'arrive en
général à distinguer
des états émotionnels de mes
interlocuteurs pour pouvoir m'adapter
j'ai un bon communicant donc voilà
éventuellement un poste en centre
d'appel mais je reste aussi ouvert à
toute proposition si mon profil d'
aventure vous intéresserait toujours
merci beaucoup de votre attention
je reste ouvert à toute proposition de
votre part je suis intéressé si vous
l'êtes aussi d'un contact humain